the paramount network's hit drama
yellowstone
tells the story of montana landowner
john dutton and his family ranch
family is perhaps a bit of a misnomer in
this instance since dutton and his
personal land trust control more than
half a million acres of western
wilderness in the area surrounding
bozeman
from the very first moments of the
series the duttons are beset
on all sides in order to preserve his
legacy
jon has to fend off greedy carpet
bagging luxury developers
attempting to build a subdivision of
budding his land a vengeful chairman on
the local reservation hell-bent on
restoring his tribal lands
and turned coat politicians who smell
blood in the water
and may be looking to put john out to
pasture it all adds up
to a pretty dramatic brew the
yellowstone ranch is populated by a
heady mix of day laborers
branded men and john's own spoiled
children who are as much a threat to the
legacy they stand to inherit
as any billionaire developer it's also
populated by quite a bit of wildlife
and on a show like yellowstone the
natural world is always one of the most
important characters
since season one the wolves in
particular have carried substantial
thematic weight they first arrived on
the scene to provide the main attraction
for beth and rip's
morbid date night after rebuffing rip's
invitation to attend a music festival
beth agrees to a slightly less popular
type of activity you want to go get
drunk
watching wolves killing elk in the park
i'll drive the romantic evening's all
going as planned
until beth jumps out of the car to run
screaming at the wolves
rip grabs his gun and barrels after her
but she manages to make enough of a
scene to scare all the wolves away
but we think this was much more than
just a weird scene to demonstrate beth's
reckless depravity
our take is that the wolves represent
all the external predators circling the
yellowstone ranch
just waiting to tear apart the carcass
of john dutton's considerable estate
if this symbolism was ever in doubt it's
essentially confirmed in an episode
later in the season
wherein we cut to a scene of
opportunistic wolves pulling apart a
bear carcass on the outskirts of john's
land
the pack picks the bear clean to the
bone a clear message
about what's poised to happen to john's
ranch when he dies
beth a ruthless vulture capitalist at
her day job with the salt lake city
private equity firm
has been summoned back to the ranch to
apply her vicious skill set against
john's enemies
her fearless charge at the wolves
suggests that she certainly has the guts
to pull it off
but is her particular brand of scorched
earth corporate warfare
really the right solution for the
yellowstone in season 3
the wolves are back and even more loaded
with meeting
in the second episode a wolf creeps up
on a private moment between
casey and monica monica is startled by
the inner loper but casey reassures her
that the wolf just wants to watch
they continue with their tryst in front
of the wolf and everybody seems fine
with this arrangement
later casey has a straight-up
conversation with a wolf
offering to cut a deal so that the
wolves can have free run of the wildlife
on the yellowstone
just as long as they stay away from the
horses and domesticated cattle
assuming this wolf speaks for the pack
it seems like they reach a meeting of
the minds
once a metaphor has been established a
writer can use it to foreshadow
and that seems to be what's going on
here casey's special relationship with
the pharaoh predators tells us a lot
about where we might be headed
is it possible that casey the prodigal
son
might be the only dutton with the skills
and the temperament to stave off the
scavengers
and preserve the yellowstone legacy
after the patriarch is gone
it certainly fits with everything we've
seen so far and even considering all of
casey's baggage
he still seems better suited to the task
than any of his siblings
beth might be able to temporarily scare
away a pack but casey is the only one
who can negotiate a stable
enduring peace check out one of our
newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you